[Music]
as most of you know although people out
in television land and Internet land
this tournaments already over but it's
not for us here we're gonna talk about
the feed a Grand Prix today it's the
last Grand Prix in the cycle and this
Grand Prix is taking place in Paris
although that's actually a lie it's in
the suburb of Paris but don't tell
anybody to decide who the next world
chess champion is they're gonna have a
candidates tournament next year
so when Anand losses to Carlsen in a
couple of months and Carlson's there
world champion we have to find a
challenger for him and they're gonna
have a candidates tournament and the
person who wins and comes in second in
the Grand Prix will get a place in that
tournament one players already
determined Veselin Topalov he's already
won the Grand Prix second place is
either going to be Mambo jar of who's
not playing in this tournament Cara
wanna or Greece shook Greece Shooks not
having a good tournament so not Grichuk
so if Cara wanna wins is next two games
tomorrow in the next day it'll probably
be him if he gets one out of two or half
out of two probably mama dr.rob if it's
one and a half either to that I don't
know off to see what happens
so either Caron or mama järva is gonna
play for the world championship in this
candidates tournament which starts I
guess late next year now for some reason
which I actually don't understand there
were three late withdrawals and there
were three replacement players two of
them were French one is white in this
game and who was the other one and two
French guys back row and Fresa net a
third guy is some guy oh I know what is
this all moshevsky now told moshevsky is
a rather new 2750 he did very well in
the World Cup and in this tournament
coincidentally out of a dying games
drumroll
he has nine drawers that's a lot of
drawers out of nine games you try to do
that have nine drawers in there not easy
okay
and also thomashefsky had some crazy
games now this guy
why is a French player and they're
playing in France since they need some
extra players they took the best French
players so generally the other players
want to beat the French players because
they're like the local guys okay for
example if we had a super grandmaster
tournament here and somebody didn't show
up and they said hey Ben Simon go play
in that tournament then the other
players would be trying to be Ben Simon
because he's the local guy
they wouldn't succeed what they would
try now this is a game where Greece rook
is in time trouble which is every game
and he played quite badly the last few
moves he had an advantage and now he's
worse and here white broke through and
won the game you'll notice that black is
pretty passive all his pieces are on the
first rank and he managed to get one of
his pieces on the second rank amazing
and white has a lot of space White's
moving up op op op up and it's an
endgame and in the endgame you want to
move your King up and that's what white
did but Grisha didn't do that now which
one of you fine players in the audience
I keep it down back there which one of
you guys can find the breakthrough that
white made in this position if you're
home and you know the answer getting
your car drive over here use the
DeLorean go back to this date and then
you're all set
well though I would wait till after the
lecture then you really know the answers
anyone and settle down back there you
kids quiet you could answer what's the
answer
knowledge is power right a-five okay in
fact the last four moves black could
have played a five and blocked it up but
I think Grist should got into his head
I'm trying to win I'm trying to win I'm
not trying to draw and then
unfortunately he was trying to lose okay
85 we got our technical guru here and
now White's rook on a1 is going to enter
the fray and blacks King is going to be
in trouble so they started taking
everything and black didn't lose any
material but if black had played a five
that would have been all blocked up but
it would have been a draw but now it's
all open so
Black's just losing and white played a
really fantastic movie next to move it's
the kind of move I wish I get my
students to play although if my students
played it all the time then they
wouldn't get lessons for me anymore
because they'd be better than me so they
got to make some mistakes okay that's
this position in this position the most
obvious move for white to try to attack
is Knight to b5 and then the knight in
the rook and the other rook and there's
a big attack unfortunately then black
plays rook takes e4 check so let's see
if we can do that without messing
everything up and then rogue takes e4
track and okay now I don't know who has
the advantage because both sides are
attacking here but however if Y could
play Knight d5 and black couldn't play
where it takes e4 track that would be
even better and so white played just a
brilliant move here and after that move
black was losing very nice what move
could white make so that rook takes e4
is not check and the guy who saw the
game probably knows no so what does
white do here which stops rook takes e4
check now it doesn't stop rook takes e4
but softer takes e4 check yes II five
gets the job done but I don't know then
I could then I could take I guess with
the pawn or the rook and then and then
if you play it if you play 95 or b5 I
should say I can still play rookie for
check so you stop - temporarily but you
give black some new options if you don't
want rook takes e4 to be check what
white piece should be moving so that
it's not check the King right so white
did move his King he played King to d3
now when white plays Knight to b5 and
black plays rook takes e4 why it's not
in check so I can keep attacking and
there's actually no defense to that it's
unfortunate so he played some random
rook well there's nothing you can really
do can't can't move the bishop it's
illegal can't move the King as you're
blocking the bishop walk it into me
for example if you want to get mated and
I've seen some of you play so I think
some of you do want to get me Aidid King
d7 night b5 we take the pawn rook takes
check King has to go to g8 and then made
so he didn't do that because that would
get painted so instead he played work to
e5 and now Knights of b5 and now White's
threatening everything White's
threatening rook takes c7 as recommended
by the computer why it's also
threatening 9 to a 7 and white has a
very sneaky threat which is a little
harder to see because the C pawn is
pinned White's threatening Knight tased
e6 and then if you take the knight
you'll get checkmated or wouldn't lose
all your rucks now the most important
variation which was not played is rook
takes e4 that's the move that's no
longer check and now White has more than
one way to win but White has a really
cute way to win which gets rid of all of
black's pieces if you get rid of all of
your opponent's pieces then you're a
favorite right then yeah and this is a
very nice combination rook takes CA
check then you take and you could take
on c7 but then you wouldn't win but you
could take on d6 and that Forks
everything and the C pawn is pinned you
can't you can't take tonight so that
would be unfortunate right you agree see
ya
and now while blacks and Shak so black
gets out of check all right we could say
either look which rook should we take
who knows should we take the EA truck or
the e4 rook yeah II for work is better
recommended by the the crowd and then
whites winning now after night b5
instead of all this stuff happening
where white wins apiece black just
resigned okay and the worst part was all
these arrows on the board so I think
Griffiths opponent was cheating how do I
get rid of that okay so that was the
game that fresh today with white beat
and that sort of ended grease hooks
chances of winning the Grand Prix and
winning everything and going to the
candidates because he lost to this local
invitee
then we'll go to the next skin okay now
as most of you know except most of you
don't know
hikaru knock'em was playing in this
tournament and he just came in second
here at the sync fuel cup and in a very
strange turn of events he's in clear
first
now when the tournament started until
around 7:00 golf fan was in clear first
and then in round eight golf and lost to
Cara Juana
and Hikaru has been using the
tried-and-true method of winning half
the games and drawing half the games
unlike the UNECE Giri method which is to
lose half the games of draw after yeah
that's that's not how you do it ok
onigiri not in first place to this
tournament now here he's playing the
local French player at cm back row who
likes to play on the back row no not
really
in this position black is absolutely
fine
Black's position is excellent Black has
all of his no one do that black has all
of his pieces develops he's ready to
castle his nights pretty good Hikaru
made a lot of pawn moves and has a lot
of space so it's at a cargo type of
position because it's very complicated
the pawn structure is not the same and
Hikaru likes to win he doesn't like
draws and in this tournament the other
players like to draw so there's a lot of
drugs tournament and Hikaru has a lot of
draws but he also has a lot of wins and
Carly played Queen e2 which does two
things it defends the pawns that Black
was attacking the b-pawn of the epoch
and he's preparing the Castle queenside
and then he can continue pushing his
King side pawns up
okay now bakra blundered which is good
if you're a fan of American chess
because then American players winning
right here he should either move his
Queen off of d8 and then decide which
way to cast Lord just Castle right now
but he played too aggressive he played
c5 and one of the things I tell my
students are they never listened so play
this tape over many many
times they maybe you listen when you
make a move in chess the piece or pawn
that you just moved isn't defending the
squares that it was before you moved it
so if we go back that's the piece that's
just moved the C pawn the C pawn was
protecting b5 and d5 and most of you and
Bach row would say well who cares about
that I don't need to defend those
squares now when you play C 5 you're not
defending B 5 and D 5 what's a C pawn
anymore
and even though you don't care and Bach
row doesn't care he cared later because
that's why Hikaru won the game and a car
actually won the game right now he said
if you go to the US chess forum they
would indicate that black resigned now
because they don't know when chess ends
because that's the u.s. chess governance
they don't really know how to play chess
okay and they would probably say Bach
crawl loses and 10 moves even though the
game 140 moves because well if you go to
the formula you actually see what I mean
you'll see a post I place there okay so
because d5 isn't protected by the pawn
white played very nicely the car who
took the night and then he played the
move d5 of course d5 would be quite
silly if there was a black pawn here
because you just lose a pawn for nothing
and now Bob crow realized he has a
losing position if he retreats his
Bishop then white plays efore and Queen
takes e4 and d6 and whites blacks
totally crushed now some of you are
wondering why doesn't black just take
that pawn that pawn is hanging well
that's what happened
black played Knight takes d5 how did
Hikaru punish Knight takes d5 have you
seen this game Joe it's ivory game
what's the winning move for white it
rhymes with of white a hassle they're
still throwing their brows that a vain
attempt to understand the situation
anyone King side Castle queenside that
would be the legal way right now your
Knights pinned and it's going to be pin
forever and then White's next move is
going to be pushing this pawn to e4 and
taking that night so now black is losing
a knight and usually when your
opponent's the third or fourth highest
rated player in the world they like
being ahead of Knight
that's their favorite thing to do okay
so by chrome well he probably realized
last well he was losing a knight and c5
movie made was just terrible because now
his Knights all pinned so he played
Queen a5 which gives his knight away but
at least he gets some some counter play
down here and if you were playing a
lesser opponent maybe two pawns is worth
a piece but not against a Caro so
especially when the pawns are doubled
cargo played Queen c2 defending his King
and letting the knight go to e to the
knight on g 1k now has the center square
c3 which just tries to confuse the
situation
notice the discovered attack on the rook
so he was trying to confuse the the way
the game would go now what very nice
move did Hikaru make to make sure that
not only he saves his rook but he could
win this pawn later not an easy move
defined because if you move your rock
black could take the pawn on beat soo is
check or play Queen a1 check first and
black has some play black would have a
lot of past pawns but White has a move
where you can't take on b2 and you save
your rook anyone save your work save
your beep on save for the future Joe you
know ah but you can figure it out
I can hear them yelling at home they're
yelling the answer out can't you hear
them listen to the future see the rook
is a hanging and the beats hoop Ana's
attacked how do you save both of them
I'm sure Ben knows
but you're gonna be the local player so
yes yeah b3 now Queen said shirk is
illegal because it's illegal and we save
our pawn and we're gonna win the c3 pawn
Bhakra didn't want to give his Queen
away or trade Queens so he checked
Hikaru made the best move highly
recommended Queen B 1 and then he moved
his Queen away and then Rick aides
choose quite a nice move also because
now he can control the e2 square move
his knight their rook a to catching the
Queen yeah and blacks position is a
little shaky because the other thing was
shaking yeah
and whites gonna win the C pawn and then
why it's gonna be up a knight and he
likes being up a knight so he was pretty
happy about that
and then black played on forever because
black didn't want to resign but well
okay black swans aren't dangerous
so yeah this isn't going to be difficult
for Hikaru
yeah okay now after h5 he realized he's
gonna lose his b3 pawn because the White
King is gonna go take it it he'll be
down the night for no pawns but
basically he lost the game earlier when
he let white play d5 and one of the
problems was being a top player and so
you're a little shaky okay when you guys
in the audience when you play your
fellow you know 1300 players and I was
being nice there and you make an error
it's likely they will make an error
later and everybody's happy maybe not
your opponent but and then the game is
filled with errors there's a lot of
fighting there's a lot of up and down
and then somebody wins at the top level
it's likely if you make one mistake
that's it you're gonna just lose you
could play as well as you want but your
opponent's just too good so at the top
level if you make one mistake and
blunder upon or in this case blunder at
night for a pond that's it you're just
gonna lose and these guys have a lot of
pressure on them and that's why we see a
lot of draws because they're playing
sort of conservatively and akaru doesn't
like to do that the Carver likes to play
aggressive and he likes to win now this
is the game in question actually
we're on well a car we won very quickly
and on us chess forum the headline was
the car wins and 14 moves and I said the
car didn't win at 14 was they said while
he was winning okay now I have a student
who plays both sides of this opening his
name is Matt Larson and Matt broke 2,100
his last tournament and when I started
teaching him two years ago he was 1,100
so in two more years will be 3,100 okay
then he'll play in the Sinquefield Cup
okay but I'll still be giving you
lessons every week
well maybe not I think that's up math
works anyway Matt Larson has white and
black in this opening this is a grünfeld
and a lot of the strong grandmasters
played this opening so I asked him what
would you play what would you play with
both sides and they got this position in
here
this is the game Nakamura's white
against Cara Juana and if you know what
an American passport is I just copied
mine today don't tell anybody
these are the two best players in the
world was an American passport although
the player was black doesn't play for
America he is American but he plays for
Italy and he does not live in Italy I
hope you learned a lot today
ok and Caruana is one of the top five
players in the world as is Hikaru and
whether both going up so there might be
two and three soon anyway this position
it was unfortunate
it's a very complicated sharp line where
one side castles Queen side and one side
castles King side and both sides played
for an attack and since it's still
theory it would behoove them to know a
lot of theory and to have a lot of
preparation and to have analyzed this
beforehand and Caruana
has had black in similar positions many
times but never this exact position and
Caruana thought forever and ever and
ever and for those of you in the
audience that means usually between 40
minutes in an hour on one move not for
the whole game not for the whole
tournament
okay he played nine takes d4 which is
okay nothing wrong with that and then
white took on g6 and now this early in
the game black made the losing move and
not only was it a losing move but they
knew it was a losing move but he didn't
know it so I hate when that happens in
fact I've done that twice than I can
remember that I've made moves in the
opening that a book would tell you just
loses but I didn't know so I need the
move and I lost okay okay I've played a
lot of chess game so I can do it
occasionally these guys also play a lot
of chess games so occasionally they do
it and Cara Juana didn't know this
position even though if I looked at my
database today and I saw four
grandmaster games in this position and
all four grandmasters played the same
move and those games were very
complicated but Cara Juana made a move
this never been played because it loses
and he was thinking a long time he
know the position he miscalculated he
took with the H pawn and that actually
losses immediately you should take with
the F pawn and the reason is if you take
with the F pawn okay and then if I take
and you take and I threaten checkmate on
h7 or check you could move your epon
let's say e5 and your queen defends your
pawn sideways
okay so black is okay here but he didn't
play F take g6 he played a chaise g6
yeah now you you you can't move your
queen through two pawns you can only be
queen through one pawn so now that
doesn't work so that's unfortunate he
did take tonight and now well Cara wanna
played a crazy move but if you play the
normal move which is to take with a
bishop which is what I just showed you
and then I play Queen h6 yeah
now I have a very strange threat so and
say I think my threats impossible to
stop so let's make a random move so I
can show you my threat check I sacrifice
the exchange and then I check and you
have to take it because there's no other
legal move and then I check and then I
take your rook and whites up a piece and
the bishops pinned that's well up a
piece is good enough okay okay so well
that's just winning for white in Cara
wanna realized that was winning for
white so I don't know maybe he I don't
know what he didn't see we'll have to
ask him okay so after this he's just
losing well he took with the Queen and
now White has many winning moves it's
always good to have any winning moves
okay so whites and move and women trio
fact the Cara want a queen for a ruck
which is pretty good
suggestions you unknown Queenie - I
think you play Queenie one but it's the
same maybe you play Queenie - okay
Queenie one and the idea is or skewering
the rook and the other rook the rook and
the other look look that's how the Queen
right what can you translate please the
Queen and the other rook yeah for some
reason Russians call King and night to
interchange them I don't know why okay
they do it on me to face I've heard it a
lot okay so I did Queen and rook so I
don't know they move that way so we're
skewing the Queen and the rock and
there's nothing to do now some players
like me would maybe resign here maybe if
I was playing certain players if I was
playing you I would just buckle down and
win later but okay I mean well I would
be most of you in this position most of
you okay I mean I mean all of you about
being nice so okay so well losing in
1015 moves is a little embarrassing I
lost in 10 moves about see what yours
this is about 20 years ago I lost in 10
moves because I also lost my queen for a
rock but I resigned okay Cara wanna did
not resign he just lost his queen for a
rock okay now Hikaru's white here but
it's clear from this position that Bach
Rocha be white BAM back row yeah thank
you I'll be here all night now he tried
for an attack night a for attacking
nothing so that didn't work out so well
now a cargo played he five blocking the
bishop but black has another Bishop and
then he defended the pawn so the bishop
on g7 isn't very good game and now Cara
wanna did something I tell my students
to do when they're losing but usually do
it when they're winning and then that's
ridiculous
but when you're losing then it's less
ridiculous he played crazy attacking
sacrificial chests but since he's down a
queen I don't really blame him if he was
up a queen then I would blame him he
played a four and then Knight B three
check
he's down to Queen anyway so you might
as well play four tricks and then he
played a three and he Queen de pon and
he won no that's not what happened
No so Hikaru played Queen to see three
is gonna block the pond east six is a
very strange move to make when you're
down a queen so I I guess when you're
2,800 got used to being down a queen
does that experience I should take over
I'd be like Ghana Queen normal okay
ninety three Queen a one and now a car
was gonna start trading pieces because
he's up a queen always a good idea and
then okay now he's down a queen for an
exchange that's pretty bad she has a
queen and night for a rock now I wrote a
book recently and there's a whole
chapter on Queen and night versus rook
and in this chapter Queen and Knight
does well okay maybe Caruana hadn't seen
that book man when you play Bishop
before that's I mean I I've been
insulted before this is funny when I see
stuff like this I think to myself if I
was white they would be playing on here
and I'd be like what what an insult but
they're playing on against a cargo to so
I don't know I guess people don't like
to resent anymore okay and a cargo
started the meeting attack and then he
realized man I'm done a lot of material
okay so he resigned yeah that's pretty
bad so that was just like an opening
gaffe but it was an opening that he
plays a lot and it was very complicated
you couldn't really afford to make a
mistake okay but Hikaru didn't mind okay
now one of the things I think that cargo
is not done in the last few years which
he's doing here is he's taking his
chances
he's just playing normal moves and when
his opponents go crazy he wins what his
opponents don't go crazy there's a draw
so he has all wins and draws he's in
first place okay other players of this
tournament like Chris Rock and Geary and
let's see who else there's another guy
who's playing crazy well there's one
other guy who's playing crazy they lose
a lot because they try to make the game
crazy then they're like I'm losing okay
and if Carlos is actually playing pretty
boring this turn
and taking his chances when they come
and today for example if you're
following the tournament there was all
draws today very exciting for the
spectators okay well what you gonna do
but Hikaru likes when it's all draws
because he's in first place that's good
math if you're in first place and it's
all drugs you're still in first place
so I can't complain about that okay and
the last game of the day so here this is
the game of the day on ICC two days ago
between Cara Juana and gelfand now this
is a very important game because golf
fans in first place and Cara wanna just
lost to her car ooh so he's in second
place and Cara wanna won this game so
that actually pushed her cargo up in
first and golf Ian down in a second so
Hikaru was sort of happy about this now
I was very interested in this game
because Golf Sam played a line that I
play although he lost so if I had played
black and lost it wouldn't be my fault
either okay in this position Delphian
plays Knight c6 nowadays he wants to
play this fashion akov Sicilian and he's
analyzing all the way to move 40 that he
gets the time control pretty quickly
game and that was only half of a joke
because he probably has analyzed to move
forty and a lot of players play Bishop
b5 because that has slightly less Theory
attached to it and that of ways all the
open Sicilian lines that golf and has
memorized now it used to be everybody
played g6 and because of that I was
playing a six-man the arrows are getting
me I thought I got rid of those who
would have thunk it okay those are crazy
arrows okay this was a crazy yeah yeah
okay so I used to play e6 and when I say
used to I mean I still do but when I
played e6 everybody played g6
so I usually knew more theory than my
opponent then these guys like golf fan
and Kramnik and Reggie Boggs started
playing six you know taking away my
thunder ruining my game right I couldn't
get car insurance it was terrible so
well now everybody plays d6 and
I play East 6th I just play 30 moves a
theory and I lose but I used to be I
knew he six okay now in this position
white plays either c3 or rook e1 and I
have many games to prove that and if you
follow top-level chess
you'll know there was a match between an
on and golf end and they had this
position occasionally and an odd was
always playing b3 and drawing okay but
he played d4 Carolina and I'm not
familiar with this move but it's been
played many times but not as many as the
other moves and this move takes two
systems and mixes them it takes the
Bishop b5 Sicilian and the open Sicilian
and white plays them both and it's funny
in this position golf and just thought
forever on every move 2030 minute things
on every move okay just like you guys do
because he wasn't familiar with this
position and I have to tell you I don't
know the move d4 so White's playing an
open Sicilian with the move Bishop b5
which I guess is okay
and immediately Caruana played a novelty
in this position white usually develops
a piece but he played c4 so already
we're out of theory there's no
Grandmaster games at all and by this
point white had a 45-minute time
advantage and golf fan was thinking
forever on every move so I'm I guess the
cart was happy because golf had had more
points than Hikaru and this is also the
round if you're following a tournament
where the cargo was slightly worse most
of the game against Yvonne truck and
then in an equal position Eve on track
lost on time so it was a very
interesting round because today for
example was six draws and this round has
like all decisive games so that was a
good game of the day for me okay so they
didn't do anything they played sort of
boring and they got to this position
okay and this is the key position I
think
and now golf fans started playing badly
so white play g3 and he's trying to kill
this knight on g6
good and probably what black should have
done is after the move g3 instead of
playing d6 he probably should have
rerouted his Knight to e6 he could have
played rook d8 for example and then
played Knight FA 96 because that's a
very good square for the knight because
the g6 square is a terrible square but
okay he didn't do that he played d6 now
he's slightly worse and then in this
position he played a move that anybody
would play but it's just an awful move
okay he should be ashamed to somebody
have his phone number I'll call him
right now in fourth item okay I mean
yeah Delphian even I could beat him oh
yeah okay so yeah here White's slightly
better and black made in my opinion the
losing move although it looks sort of
innocuous so well what black has two
problems here his pawn structures weaker
than White's he has some weak pawns here
a sevens weak c6 is potentially weak d6
and White has more space why it's going
to move his pawns up and black doesn't
really have a good plan but I can't
really do anything active and the move
he played was just awful rook to see it
terrible okay where's the cargo where is
he oh he's there it's the tournament
okay if a Cara was watching the game he
would have been shaking his head now for
sure because rook c8 undefended the a7
pawn and white takes that pawn in two or
three moves he's a pawn up okay and
White has a very simple plan which is
very hard to stop and it was not stopped
why he wants to play b5 take this pawn
and then put his knight on d5 and then
say ya have a knight on d5 and and then
he'll win this pawn when he feels like
it and then I don't know if this bishops
supposed to do or this Knight they can't
move anywhere so what black should have
done was play the other rook to c8 okay
you should play like me not like himself
terrible then this pawn is defended and
now my knight can come back to the
senator okay that would make more sense
because the knight on g6 is just sitting
over there okay so maybe golf here wants
lessons he knows
I am okay and okay so rook ca not good
b5 now another very strange move Bishop
to d8 he wants to put his Bishop over on
the Queen side and move his but he's
just losing upon okay Rick see one
that's a good move getting his rook to
this correct side of the board and then
he takes and just just terrible position
you can't take with the Queen because
you're a pawn singing yeah and you can't
do anything but I can't move the knight
when to d5 the a7 point is weak White
has the only open file Black is very
passive now gelfand realized his game
was bad so he sacrificed a pawn for
complications Bishop b6 because his
bishop is terrible anyway then a white
Suparna head and a white has a past a
pawn and black got rid of his bad bishop
but okay I mean the past pawn ahead so
here I knew it was over and I had faith
that Carter Lana would have good
technique he didn't let me down and he
just pushed his a pawn okay that's good
idea getting a queen is a good idea and
black has no - I can't do anything
Black is just passive so white was it no
hurry at all because he's a pawn up he
has two bishops black has no play he's
all happy and now he plays f4 taking
advantage of the fact that black's
pieces are trapped over here they can't
really go to this side of the board
so yeah White's winning everywhere and
now tricky ones a great move
so most people would be tempted to play
Bishop to g2 because it attacks a lot of
rooks
what's wrong with Bishop - G - who knows
it gives black the counterplay that he
wants now all for Brooks will be
captured somehow it's illegal but it'll
happen anyway but this is the kind of
complicated position the golf Ian's
hoping for all the rooks are hanging and
white wants no complications because
White's apart up for nothing
so rookie one taking control of the
e-file d5 a crazy move but he's losing
anyway so he gets to check him at least
check that's pretty good he checked his
opponent okay now he's down to pawns and
his Knights hanging on c5 so he saved it
a tribe attacking the rook bishop h3
attacking the rook the rook can't move
anywhere because you lose your bishop
with check so Knight to f6 now if this
is the beginner class I could spend 15
minutes on Bishop takes rook but it's
the intermediate class so I it's mainly
a joke then Knight takes woodwind the
Queen so Cara Juana decided not to hang
his queen and he played Queen of c1 so
he wants to trade Queens and then he'll
have to passed pawns and he also wants
to take the rook now he could take the
rook safely black didn't want to trade
Queens and he attacked the rook on b4 so
the rook moved away and and then he took
that rook and White's up an exchange in
two pawns now this actually reminds me
of a game that I won where I was down
the exchange in two pawns because my
opponent made several mistakes but I
wasn't playing Cara Juana so okay black
threatens Queen h2 and white stops it
and that's sort of the end of the
threats for black and he's just done a
lot of material yeah and then he's like
mom this isn't good
why it's getting a queen and I'm down
the exchange although that would be like
a car who's game in round one he won
where he was up the Queen in the
exchange so similar material situation
and and here golf fan resigned so Cara
Juana was happy Hikaru was happy and
golf fan was not happy and it was the
only game of the event thus far the golf
and lost but back to the drawing board
with that
six I'm glad I didn't face that line
because I could have lost like that and
that was a game where Cara wanna did
some good psychological preparation this
opening was prepared by gelfand for his
match with anand so Cara wanna avoided
all theory getting out of theory I move
five and just playing some strange moves
and then golfin has to play his own game
golf fan got in time trouble never got
an active position and lost although he
has a nice diamond formation here so you
gotta get you got to give him that he
did something okay yeah but okay white
had too many past pawns and too many
bishops so that was a great game for
Caruana especially after the last game
where Cara wanna lost his Queen I move
15 this game he played better see and
don't tell giri cuz man that's that's a
bad tournament usually when you have a
super grandmaster tournament one of the
players is having a bad tournament
because there's so many players it
happens to be Gary and one thing I don't
understand and I'll never understand is
golf and is back Delphine's 45 years old
he won the tall memorial and if you
don't believe me ask him he was there
okay right it's a D he win were you
there when he wanted you often already
you were shocked yeah and then and now
golf fan was in first place of this
tournament until this game so 45 is the
new you know some 32 22 11 44 yeah so if
I get as old as golf hands someday I'll
be good okay but I'm a little soo young
well of course he lost his skin but then
he drew the next round
he played Eve on truck and they boy did
they make sure the game was a draw if
you saw that game okay that's a
organizers nightmare every piece is
traded in the positions blocked up
okay very suspicious okay now one of the
players in the event told moshevsky has
9 draws a perfect score but all his
games are actually exciting but somehow
they're drawing so for those of you
watching at home I'm assuming this takes
more than one day to put on the Internet
so that means this tournaments over and
hopefully the car won if a car away
is next two rounds he'll be number two
in the world that's pretty good
I forgot my number oh yeah Carlson yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]